えっと まああの 早速話に入りますけど
今日は無我のこの前の話の続きで
で  2番目なんです で 前回の話はまあ少々わかりにくかったかもしれません
えーと それはちょっと順番の違いなんです
この話を計画立てると
まあ一般的に考えて まず無我って何ですかとかね
そういう紹介とか そういうことをして
それから仏教の無我の話という風にやりますけどね
やっぱりそういう一般的に考えて話を計画立てると
まあ仏教の無我はわからなくなっちゃうんです
逆にしたならば 仏教で言っている無我は何ですか？とした方が分かりやすかったかもしれません
今日は仏教における無我の話ですから
まあなんとなくわかるだろうと思います
それから どう見たっても無我を理解することだというのは
本当は仏教でいう悟ることなんです
無我を知ることと同時に
我々の心にある一切の悩み苦しみ
全部消えてしまっちゃうんです
ですから 無我っていうのは一種の体験であります
理解ではないんです で
理解するものは無我についてのものであって
またそれも一種の画的な考え方なんですね
そういうちょっとちょっと難しいところはあるんです
で 前の話の続きですから
まあ前回いらっしゃらなかった方々はわからないだろうと思うかもしれません
だから一応今日のお話は今日のお話でまとめるように喋ります
ですから 前回の話を聞かなくても
今日のお話だけでも理解できると思います
で 前の続きとしてはお話はいたしません
で 我々よく知っている初期仏教のキーワード
3つあります 私たちはそれをよく知っているんです
それは無常 苦 無我という 3つの言葉なんですね
パーリ語でアニッチェ
ドゥッカ アナッタと言うんですね
アナッタというアナッターでいいと思います
で 日本語で言えば無常
苦 苦しみの苦と無我ですね
ダンさん代わりますか？お願いします
あ 一応日本語の決まってる日本語の言葉は
この無常 苦 無我と で 私はいつでも言うのは
ただ言葉を見ただけで
あ わかったぞという気持ちだけだったら
もう何もわからなくなるんです
何でも初めて聞くようなつもりで
チャレンジ精神で聞かなきゃ物事はわからないんです
私たちは言葉によって確実に騙されているんです
それはどういうわけかというと
我々は言葉っていうのはもう 2
3歳になるともうほとんど勉強して終わっているんです
その時の意味で我々の人生は全部理解しようとすると
それは正しく正しいとは言いにくいんです
そこで問題は 何か言葉を言った途端
そのちっちゃな子はあ
わかったよという感じになっちゃうんですね
それから少々新しい言葉を付け加えていますが
やっぱり基本的なことは全部
もう ３歳ぐらいになっちゃうと
もうもうできているんですね
そういうわけで この本当に新しい智慧が欲しいんだと
新しいものを発見したいという人が
やっぱりいつでもこの言葉について気をつけなくちゃいけない
どういうことかというと
やっぱり知ってるんだという気持ちになっちゃうんですね
これは私にも勉強 学生頃よく注意されたことなんですね
仏教を勉強を始めたら
まず先生方に言われたのは
あなた方は教室は大きかったんだから
よく仏教の言葉とかね
小さい時から聞いてよく知ってるだろうと思ってるんだけどね
それは全部きれいさっぱり忘れなさいと
全く初めて聞くんだと
この子の言葉 無常という言葉であろうが
無我という言葉であろうが
全く初めて聞く 話だと
そういう気持ちで一切の固定概念を置いておいて聞かなきゃ
立派な研究者にはなれませんと
単なる固定概念でやらやらされていて
もう何のも新しいことも発見もできなくなりますから
固定概念を全部捨てなさいということは言われてから受業を始めたんですね
ですから考えれば やっぱりそれはその通りで
違うことを言われると
まあ気持ち悪くなっちゃうというか
怒るというか 腹が立ったりするということはあるんですね
そうするとやっぱりどういうわけかというと
自分たちが思っている考え方と
その同じ言葉を持って
向こう側が言うことを違う場合は
やっぱり気持ちは良くないんですね
それで怒ったり あんた何言ってるんですか？と批判したりはする
そういう心精神的なトラブルを起こしちゃうんですね
だから知識を求めている人
知恵を求める人が 自分すでに持っている考え方にどう攻撃されても
何のことなく向こう側が何を言ってるんですかということで
それを理解しようとする
どうせ新しい考え方を聞くと
我々の今すでに持っている固定概念は壊れるはずなんです
もし固定概念が壊れなかったら
その人は何も言ってないんです
ただ言葉で美しい言葉で遊んだだけになっちゃうんです
自分が自分の考え方が変わってないと言った人は何も言ったことにならない
特にこの世の中で人気のある話というものがありますね
それなんで人気あるかというと
話を聞く方々は その通りやその通りやと
私もそう思っていたんだと
そういう気持ちで聞くと
みんなすごくいい話だと言うんです
その通りや その通り 私もそういうふうに思っていたんだと
私も同じ意見だというふうに
ものすごい抜群に共感できて
笑って楽しくて話が終わったということはすべて無駄話でしたね
ということなんです すべて無駄話でしたと
満載と同じと ですから
この智慧を求めている人っていうのは
かなり心の中でいろんな葛藤やら混乱やら出てきたりして
それをいろいろ解決しながら自分が成長していくんですね
ですから 新しい知識 新しい智慧
新しい理解を得るということは
あのちょっと苦しい仕事なんです
おだててもらいたいという場合は
その人は何の知識智慧は得られないんです
で 攻撃というか ショックというものは受ける可能性はいくらでもあります
そういうわけで 無常とか空とか無我とか
言葉を聞いた途端 あ わかったよということだったら
まあちょっと困るんですね
わかったよではなくて
無常ってなんですか？と新しく考えなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで これはまあ今日説明する必要はないんですけど
まあずっと喋ってるんだから
そのポイントについては
で 一応今日のテーマに必要なところだけ説明します
で アニッチャ無常というのは
すべての現象 自分と他ですね
一切の現象を観察したところで
じゃあ一切の現象について何か一言葉で言えるものが何かあるかと
全部まとめて一切の現象はどういうものかというと
でお釈迦様が言っているのは
無常ということは言えるんだと
そういうわけで それに真理と言うんです
だから どんな人がどんな現象を確かめてみても
そこに無常ということはあるんです
だからすべてのものに共通しているものだから
真理と言うんです で 無常の説明
またかえって難しいかもしれませんだけど
私はその話になるといろいろ説明しますけどね
それはまあ 物事は現象として一時的に現れるものであって
変化していく 変化しないものは何一つもないと
変化すること自体が存在であると
ものがあるという言葉が正しければ
ものが変化しているという意味なんです
そこで言葉に引っかかる人々があるという言葉に引っかかっちゃうんです
あるんだからあるんじゃないかと
で よく考えると あるということは変化していくということで
今あるということは 次の瞬間にその状態ではないんですね
それはわかります と思います
ですから 一切私たちの体と外の世界と他の生命と
みんな一つのダイナミズムでずっと変化している
変わって変わっていく
その変わることに 存在と一般的な人々の言葉を借りて言えるんです
あるいはもっと具体的な例に行きましょう
光があると 蛍光灯は光っていると
そこであるという言葉になるんですね
蛍光灯は光っている そこにそれはあるんでしょうし
でもそこは無常でなければ
その現象 蛍光灯光っているという現象は成り立たないんですね
そこであ わかった この蛍光灯のランプだけは変化しているんだと
それは違います なんで蛍光灯のつけてる他の部分が変化しないんです
それも変化しているんです
そうでなきゃあるわけじゃないんです
私がいるという場合も
この体が変化してなきゃいるということには言えません
ですから 厳密に理解してほしいのは
世の中でいろんな人が存在しているんだ
あるんだ 実体があるんだ
何かもう魂 霊魂 種みたいなもの
変化しないものあるんだと言っても
それは言葉の誤りであって
言葉に引っかかっているのであって
彼らはちゃんと言語学を勉強していないというか
理解していないということだけであって
あるという言葉は成り立たない
本当は論理的には成り立つのは変化しているんだ
変わっていくんだということなんです
人が変わっていないと
ここに人がいるという仮の言葉は使えません
だからいるいないというのは
二次元的な論理で西洋的な理解しやすいんですね
ここに人がいる あるいはないと
どっちですかと イエスとノーで
この二元論ですか その二元論というのは
ヨーロッパの論理学は二元論で成り立っているんですね
インドは 4元論になっているし
仏教はその 4元論も否定することを成り立たせ
否定ではなくて成り立たないと
ということで仏教の論理があるんですね
成り立たないというところで
もう大変難しいようになってしまっちゃいます
そこら辺を勉強したい
したい方々というのならば
ナーガルジュナさんのテキストをいろいろ解釈もつけていっぱいありますので
読んでみたら この 4元論をね
どのように成り立たないことを説明しているかということを明確に説明しているんです
で そこでこの二元論でここに人がいる
あるいはない そういうふうに考える場合は
それは便利な言葉の便利な使い方であって
で 我々から仏教の立場から見れば
そんなに確かな意味があるわけじゃないんです
人があるということ自体は
そこに人がいないということですよと
それははっきりと この金剛般若心
金剛般若経で般若経ですか
ワッチャッチャディカーパニャパーミタという大乗経典があります
そこでそういう項目だけザーッと並んでいってるんです
ここに仏がいるということは
ここに仏がいないことやと
菩薩は一切衆生を救済するんだということは
菩薩は一切衆生を救済しないということやと
そうすると この人々は何言ってるんですかと
なんか分かりませんと思うかもしれませんだけど
すごい簡単単純な論理を言ってるんです
ここに人がいるということは
そこで今瞬間いた人は
今の次の瞬間に変わらなきゃ
だから人がどこにいるんですかね
私はいるという人がもうすぐ変わっていっちゃったんだから
見た光が瞬間に消えて違う光ですからね
光があるといっても その見た瞬間の光がもう消えているんだから
違う光なんで光なんです
ですから あるということはないということですよと
だから結局 仏教はこういう一般の人々が使っている
この単純な言葉で遊んでいるんですね
言葉には引っかかるなと思うが
何の意味もないんだと
言葉の中には あんた ここに人があると言ったで
それ大嘘だよと 本当に言葉に引っかかってあると思っちゃうんです
あれは大嘘であって変化するんだから
まあ言葉を借りて 世俗的に一般的な言葉でまああるということは言えるだけのことで
実際はないという ことですよ
そういうのは無常の考え方なんですね
じゃあ そんな風に喋ると
また仏教っていうのはちょっとこの論理学者やら言語学者やら
そういう哲学者の世界になってしまっちゃうんですね
でも お釈迦様はそういう風にいちいち訳も分からない
この人間 頭狂っちゃうような
あるっていうことはないということだよとかね
で あなたはとこを住むということは
あなたは何のとこも住んでないことやとか
そんなことをお釈迦様は言えません
それは前言った このワジラチェディカプラクティナパーリミタスウットラという金剛般若経というのは
もうお釈迦様の教えではないんですね
それはもう大乗経典で
随分後で遊びで書いた経典だろうと思います
ちょっと遊んでやろうではないかと
そこでお釈迦様はどのように無常としゃべる？無常のことをしゃべりますかというと
もう何でもいいんだから見てみなさいと
物事を我々は自分を理解できる立場で見たらいいんです
日常茶飯事のことを 例えばご飯を見ましたと
じゃあご飯はずっとその通りにあるんですかと
いえ その通りにいません
食べて食べられて消えるか
そのまま放っておけば腐って
いろいろウジ虫ができたりとかね
あるいは土に戻るかと
止まっていないんですね
自分の形が変化して 全く別質なものに変わるんですね
そこで我々はご飯を持ってきて
それはもうちょっと土と混ぜて
もう土に戻るということで
もう置いておいてければ
それは肥料というものになっちゃうんですね
じゃあ肥料とご飯というのは全く同じものですかね
全く働きも機能も全部違うでしょうに
ご飯は人間にも動物にも食べられますが
肥料は植物の栄養にしかならないんですね
ですから 物事っていうのはそうやって本質的にも変化していくんです
変化しちゃったら あれ？これはもともとどんなものでしたかとわからないんです
この前私も同じ説明しましたけど
今私は喋ってるっていうのは前食べたご飯なんですけど
そのエネルギーは出してますけど
これはおにぎりかパンかどっちかと言えますかね
今喋ってる言葉のエネルギーは
この音は これはもう何といいますか
梅干しの匂いがするんだから
梅干しだと 魚の匂いがするんだから
これもうおそらく焼き魚のなんとかの焼き魚のエネルギーだと言えますかね
まるっきり言えるどころか
もうまるさっぱりなんかわからない
ただ簡単に言えるのは
まあご飯食べただろうと
それぐらいのことなんです
それぐらい跡形もなく変化するんです
物事は ですから それは我々の日常経験でわかるもので
産んだ母親の子供は 例えば 1歳
2歳で取り上げられちゃって
それで 10年後  15年経ってみたらわからないでしょうに
跡形もなく変化しているんです
そういう風にものすごい
このもう大胆的に変化していくんです
で 私たちは花というものと
その花を作ってくる植物というのはどれほど違うかというと
みんな好きな桜の花とかあるでしょう
桜の花と桜の木と比べちゃうと
何かありますか？似ているもの
何もないんでしょう 花にはかすかに香りがあるんだけど
木には全然ない 花がこんな小さくて
木はすごい大きくてとかね
指ででもつぶれちゃうし
桜の木はもう自分も潰れるかもしれません
全く別質なものを作っちゃうんです
そういうすべてのものを何見てもあると思うものは全部無常なんです
ないものには無常が関係ないんです
それの仏教ですごい有名な例えありまして
この空空下という言葉がありますね
禅でも使ってますけど
空の花という漢字を書くんですけどね
空と花と書いてね 空に咲いた花というのはありえないことなんです
そこは存在しないんだから
そこには無常という関係はないんですね
例えばウサギの角 いくらでも言えます
馬の翼はどうですか？とかね
亀の毛とかね そういう使ってる
伝統的に使ってる例えなんですね
亀さんの毛について喋ってるんだと
そんなものは存在しないんですね
馬の翼といえば だから存在しないんだから
そっちに そちらについては無常か無常でないかとかね
そんなもう関係ない話
ただ人間が言葉二つ繋げただけ
亀の毛といえば 亀という言葉と毛という言葉が繋げただけのことで実在しない
でも実在するあると言うならば
その町無常であって その町ないということなんです
そこでお釈迦様っていうのは
そういうふうに世の中見てね
まあ見たらどうですかねとかね
見たら変わるでしょ なんだかんだも
というふうなことで 一般の人に理解できるように
まあそうやってあなたは見るものも聞くものも
あなた自身も あなたのお友達やら親戚やら子供たちやらね
みんなももう変わって変わって
消えて消えていくんだと
言葉使うとちょっと実体的な気持ちが入っちゃいますけどね
私が変わりますと言ったら
なんか私がいるような感じがしますから
そこはややこしいところで
言葉使わなきゃ喋れませんだからね
そこら辺ちょっと気をつけると
まあ無常はわかるんですね
そこで私は今日言いたいのは
無常っていうのは人間の日常の経験なんですね
だから日常に我々には毎日経験できる
体験できる 味わう心理
エクスペリエンスですね
人間の経験から見れば
すべての現象は無常である
ですから それには証明は要りません
人が私を殴って痛がったと
で 私にはこの自分が痛いということに証明必要ですかね
要りません 痛いこと自体は証明なんです
ですから 無常であることには特別に証明は要りません
わからないものを経験できないものには証明は必要なんです
遺体は見つからない場合は
人を その人が死んでいるだろうということには
ありとあらゆる証明を出さなくちゃいけない
遺体見つかったらもう
こういうわけで この人死んでるんですよという必要はないんです
もう死んでるんですよ
ですから この経験ですから
それには証明要りませんということだけ覚えておいてください
一切は無常である じゃあ証明してくださいということはバカバカ
らしいです 人が無常ではありませんと言ったら
証明出してくれと言った方が正しいんです
理由を言ってくださいと
それなのに 一切は無常であることには証明要りませんなのに
お釈迦様はきちんとなぜ無常かということを説明しているんです
それは仏教における因縁論の話なんです
いわゆる物事には実体がなくて
一時的に組み立てられて現れるものだと
そこでキリがない あるものは我々は作ったとする
それは一時的に 例えばここに袋ありますから
袋が作ったものだから永遠じゃない
変化していく じゃあ袋を作った部品が永遠かというと
それもできたものだから
それも変化する じゃあそれできたもの
またできたものだから
そうやってキリがなく
もう全部できているもの
作られているもの 組み立てられているもので
サンカーラという言葉を使っているんですね
そこで何で組み立てるか
どのようどういうことかとかね
そこら辺はまあ因縁論の中で明確に説明しています
はい それで私は哲学的な
ちょっと言葉を借りて言うと
これはあのエンピリカルトゥルースというか
この人間の経験から味わう経験する事実ですね
ですから これわからないというと
なんかちょっとおかしいと
無常はわかりませんと
無常じゃないというならば
それ自体がおかしいんであって
ほんのちょっと目を開けたら無常であることは見えるんですね
次に無常だから 無常たるものにもう一つ
お釈迦様が言葉を使っちゃいます
ドッカだよと そこでこの漢字の空では我々は困りますけど
これ困ったってしょうがない
パーリ語でもドッカと書いて書いてますから
まあ苦しみという意味が入ってるんです
ですから無常が故にだから結局言葉としてはイコールなんです
言葉としてはいい ドッカというのはだからもう虚しいだよと
何も味がないでしょうと
例えば花を見て ああ すごい綺麗だ
私はこれ欲しいんだと
じゃあ持っていきますと
そうやって囚われて持っていっても無常だからね
あんた苦しみだけですよと
これ枯れてしまったら悲しいでしょうに
まあ花は無常ということはわかってるんだけど
それほど悲しくないんだけど
せっかく大事な花を持ってきて
満員電車に乗ったところで潰れたら腹が立つでしょうに
あれ何ですかというと
無常は認めていない これは家に持っていて
植えたところで 1週間ぐらい見て楽しんだところで
じわじわと枯れるだろうと自分で計画を立てているんです
電車で潰れるだろうということはないんです
永遠だよと そこまでは
だから無常はわかってない瞬間で
苦しみ 悩み 嫌な気持ち生まれてくる
腹が立つ ですから無常
それから一切のものについて
それでなくては何を理解するかといえば
じゃあ空だと理解してみなさいと
苦しみだと どんなものからも出てくる味わいは苦しみではないかと
で あの空にはいろいろ
ドッカにはいろいろ意味がありまして
空しい 不安 不完全という 3つの意味があるんです
ドッカのことはそこら辺で置いておいて
これは人間の経験ですね
ドッカっていうのは価値なんですね
じゃあここに人がいるということは
ここに人がいないということ
それで評価するならば
価値判断するならばドッカだよと
いわゆるまあ こちらはこの哲学的に言えば
このあのエンピリカルファクトというか
この経験できるところはこういうことや
こちらはこの なんとなく道徳的もない
倫理的でもないんだけど
なんとなく価値判断を入れなければ大事なものということは言えなくなっちゃうんですね
あ すごい大事なものやとは言えないんですね
消えてしまいますから
もう二度と戻りませんだから
あの消えた瞬間 私にとって一番大事な瞬間だから持っていけます
持っていけませんね だから光はすごく大事なものだと言ったっても
それはずっと消えて消えて消えて消えて消えていくんだから
つかめません これはもうもっとわかりやすい例で言えば
この何て言いますか えーと
えーと 虹みたいなもんなんで
虹は遠くから見れば綺麗ですけど
じゃあ触ってみてくださいと
虹は無常でなければ存在しないし
触って持っていくことはできないし
捕まえて持っていくことは
だから まあご自分たちで持っている宝石やらアクセサリーみたいに
あ これは私の大事に大変高価な宝物や
だから金庫に入れておきますよとかね
そういうふうに価値入れられますかと
物事に と価値を入れられないんですね
だから価値はないと 価値はないところは虚しいということで
価値判断との立場からドッカと言うんです
そこで一切現象は変化することは経験できる
経験できるものには 少々価値判断を入れてみようというたら
まあドッカだよと 苦しみだよと
虚しいだよと じゃあ次に我々のテーマの無我という言葉入っちゃうんです
じゃあ哲学的にというか
もっと知恵を使って何か言えることはありますか？というと
無我ですよと 実体はないんだと
ということで ですから
無我っていうのは日常茶飯事の経験ではないんですね
日常茶飯事の経験は無常なんです
それからもうちょっと知恵を働かせちゃうと
やっぱり空だよってことがわかります
さらに知恵を働かせちゃうと
やっぱり何もないんだと
本当は 実体がないんだとわかるんですね
それであるということは無常であって
あるあるがゆえにないということは無我なんです
だから あの金剛般若経なんかは
仏がいるということは仏がいないということやと
徳があるということは徳がないということだと
菩薩は一切衆生を衆生が救済するそうと思わなきゃ菩薩ではないんだけどと言って
一切衆生を救済するぞと思ったら
その意味は一切衆生を救済しないということだと
というふうに まあいろいろ面白く書いているんですね
ですから あなたっていうのは智慧から成り立つ結論ですね
でもそういうのは言葉だけのことでね
ですから 空イコール無我
で なんでそういうことをお釈迦様はおっしゃいますかというと
これは真理であって事実ですから
これを理解すると同時に
我々の一切の苦しみが消えちゃうんです
なぜ人が苦しんでいるかというと
これをわかっていないんだから
ものがあると思っているんだから
花のだとえで考えてください
花が我々はあまり長持ちはしないよとわかっているんだけど
花束を持って持って家に持っていく間は
頭で無常の概念否定するんですね
これは家まで持っていって
花瓶に入れて ああいう場所に置いておきますよと
頭の中にも計画立ててるんですね
そのためには やっぱり花が枯れてしまっちゃったら困るんですね
永遠にいてくれなきゃ
そこで電車に乗ったところで
さっと次の駅で人がいっぱい入っちゃったら
もう潰れちゃったと いうところで
すごく苦しみを味わう
ああ 嫌だと もったいないんだと
そこで人によって変わりますけど
苦しみがね まああんまりものにとらわれないで
まあしょうがない 捨てましょうということになるかもしれませんし
でもちょっと寂しいと
それはちょっとでも寂しいということは消えませんよ
無常だと思った人は 花をその場で見て
綺麗ですけど 帰りますよと帰りますからね
持っていかない だから何ですかと
だから執着ないんです
無常を知っている人にとっては持っていかない
店だってものがある あれすごい綺麗です
綺麗ですけど だから何ですかという気持ちで
別に持っていこうと 私にも一つちょうだいとかね
そこまではいかないんです
だから花束を持っていった人が
いくらできた人であろうと
持っていったこと自体がもう一時的に無常は否定しているんですね
そこで電車で潰れたりしたところで
まあしょうがない 潰れちゃったんだから捨てようというふうなことで
かすかにでも寂しいと
もったいないという気持ちがあるかもしれません
より無常は否定する人だったら
いろんな苦しみが作るんですね
あるいは自分に向かって
考える人だったら なんで私みたいなバカがいるんですか？と
人がこんなに来るんだったら
これ上に上げて持っていった方が良かったんではないかとかね
あるいは棚の上に置いた方が滑れなかったんではないかとかね
いつでも自分がアホなことばっかりやっちゃうんだというふうな感じで苦しみを味わう
自分の問題ではなくて
間違っているのは他人だよと思っている人が逆に考えちゃうんですね
なんでこの人々はもう行儀が悪いことをざっと入るんだけど
この人がいるってことは考えてないんですか？とかね
自分が乗ることしか考えませんが
とは他人にどれぐらい迷惑をかけるかどうかね
そういうふうに他人に当たるとかね
いや もう一人は全部まとめて苦しみとかね
だから苦しみの度合いがもうそのその各自によって違いますけど
苦しむことだけは確かなんですね
なんで苦しんだかというと
無常は否定したんだからなんです
例えば そこな時間でも無常を否定すると
苦しみがそこにあるんです
そういうわけで 人間が何を理解するべきかというと
無常たる無常であることは理解するべきですよと
そこで限りない安らぎが生まれるんだと
はい そういう順番で このアナッタ無我ということがどんどん成り立っている
で アナッタっていうことはなぜ入れたかというと
だいたいもう 人々が余計なことを考えるんですね
この余計なことを考えると
この我という感覚が生まれちゃうんですね
あんまり余計なことを考えないで
事実だけで留まっている人はいいんだけど
やっぱり人々はよくよく考える
で 考えて この世の中でいろんな哲学を作ってるんですね
それで世の中で我というものは固定してしまっちゃったんです
そういうわけで 仏教は無我論を喋ってるんではないかともいうようになってしまったんです
それで時々学者が仏教の古典経典を読んでみたら
あれ お釈迦様は別に無我論というふうにも言ってないんだと
それは正しいんです 私は無我論かかって語っているぞとは言ってないんだから
それで間違っている学者が何を言うかというと
お釈迦様は我を否定してないんだと
我の取り方が間違っていると言ってるだけですよと
というとんでもない間違いを起こしちゃうんです
それも単なる我論なんですね
日本の研究論文もありますけど
そんな同じことを言っている
でも皆様あまりそういう批判されるのは嫌だから
インドにいたあの何でしたっけ
サッラパリラードクリシュナンという元の大統領
もうかなりの立派な学者なんですけど
彼の仏教について書いている論文なんかございます
読んでみてください 彼ら言うのは
非我たることを我で取ることは否定しただけですよ
人は真我を置いておいて
真我でないものを我だと勘違いすることは批判しているだけですよ
ということも言ってるんです
だからもうそういう話にのっとって乗せられて
日本でも書いてるテキストではやっぱりこの同じことを言ったりはする
日本の研究の場合は特色はあるんですね
で 他の学者の考え方は真っ向から否定しない
ズルズルと逃げると抜けると
で それはまあ まあ自分が怪我したくない
怪我したくないというならば
それはすごくいいかもしれませんだけど
でも人類に正しい知識を与えるのが学者の仕事なんですね
だから堂々と言うべきですね
自分感じたこと だから結構まあ結構じゃなくて
いくつか私もいろいろ読んでみたんだけど
明確に間違っていると見えるんだけど
ズルズルとそちらは触らないことにして
次にっていう感じで言っちゃいますから
最終的には本読んで終わったっても何もないんですね
心に残ったことは まあどんと相手のことをぶつかって
こうでこうでああだこうだと言っちゃうと
何かこちらの知識として残りますし
そういうことは日本ではちょっとあることなんですけど
だからいろいろ読んだところでは
なんか非我無我とかああだこうだとかね
まあ混乱はしてあるんです
じゃあそれであの 無我という概念
これから無我に入ります
アナッタっていうこと
それもアナッタだから否定形でやって
これはアートマンではないんだと
だから肯定形はアッタなんですね
アッタということで サンスクリット語だったらアートマンなんですね
すぐ人々がアートマン実体という考え方を作ってしまったんです
作ってしまって それを探すんです
そのアートマンはどこにありますかと
ですから 最初から仏教から言うとおかしいと
あなた方は まずこういう概念だと決めてそれを探す
まあ研究の世界でもいくらかそういう傾向はありますけど
まず仮説を立てて それに証拠を探すということがありますけど
でも問題は仮説いい加減に立てられますかね
仮説を立てる時でも かなりの研究が必要なんです
研究なしに仮説を立てられません
そこら辺も気をつけてほしいんですが
要するに仮説を立てる権利はあるし
仮説を立ててから それからもう研究し続ける
それでもうそれを成立するか壊れるか
どっちかわかりませんだけど
でも仮説を作るためには十分な情報がなければ立てられないはずなんです
そこでインドの世界を見ると
そんなことない 世の中どこを見てももう我があるのは当たり前だと
もう決まってるんですね
決まってるんだけど じゃあ見つかりましょう
それからと探すんです
で そういう探し方には
お釈迦様 すごく面白いたとえ 2つありますけど
このたとえ 2つの現代我々にはちょっと理解しにくいんですが
うーん まあたとえだからね
お釈迦様の言葉をしたても
たとえはたとえだから
その当時の人間との当時の文化背景の中で理解できるようなことだからね
教えは現代人に分かりますけど
時々たとえがわからない我々
昔インドのことだからね
一つのたとえ こういうたとえなんですね
人がはしごを作っているんだと
そこで知識人の いわゆる十次郎のところではしごを作っているんだと
それでいろんなところから人を上げて
あんた何やってるの？はしご作ってるんだと
何のために そのパーサーダという言葉があります
お城  お城に登るため あ
そう そこまでわかりますね
お城を登るためには もうはしごを作っているんだと
なんか合理的に見える
そこでその人にこう聞くんですね
このお城はどこにあるんですかね
わかりませんね 答えるんです
あれ 何階建物？わかりませんと
じゃあこれは北や東 西
南北どこにあるの？知りません
そんなことは 見たことはあります
いえ 見たことはないんだと
見たことないことだから知りませんだから
じゃああんた このお城のこと聞いたことは？いえ
聞いたこともないんだ
じゃあ分かった あんた
そのお城あることさえ知ってますかと
大体 それも知りませんと
と言うならば あんた何のためにこのはしごを作ってる？いえ
このはしごもお城を登るために作っているんだと
言うとすると そうするとその人の言葉が何になるんですかと
その人は何のも根拠もない
ただ単に頑張っているだけで無意味だと
だから存在しないお城に登るために作るはしごだと
といったとて お釈迦様何を言ってますかというと
発見もしていない 存在もしない我について喋っているのではないかということは
すごく丁寧に相手を侮辱しないで言っていることなんです
それぐらいもうお釈迦様にできたんだけど
私にはできないんだから
私はもう言う時は言います
いくら腹が立っても気にしないで
私はそんなにただの人間だからね
お釈迦様みたいに丁寧にもう言うっていうことはもう無理なんです
それで皆様方はこれからいろんなこの我についてすごい明確に書いているのはインドのテキストですからね
ウパニシャッドテキストはあるし
日本訳はございますし
で またいろんな瞑想 ヨーガとかね
パータンジャリとかね
ヨーガそうしていろいろあるし
日本訳は丁寧に書いてあります
読んでみてください すべて我についてと我を体験する方法
我はなんですけど 誰も知らない
我ってなんですか？自我といわゆる実体ってなんですかと
だからお釈迦様はちょっとしたからかっているだけ
次の例えももっとものすごくからかってるんだから
すごい単純な例えなんですけど
例 2つあるんです 次の例えっていうのは
ある若者が今まあ もう結婚の年になったらね
じゃあ結婚したらどうですかと
そうですね 結婚しますと
誰と結婚しますかと いうと
インドではこのジャナパダカリャーニという
この決まってる美人美人の概念があったんですね
それも今 現代で言えば
このミス何々というふうな
全く同じことなんですね
そのミス東京 ミスミスジャパンとか言ってるでしょうし
そのミス東京には私はミス東京と言ったってももうなりませんからね
やっぱりみんな選べなくちゃいけないしね
私はミスジャパンだよと言ったっても
もう誰も笑っちゃうだけでね
でもそれちゃんとコンテストで選べたら
もうミスジャパンなんです
1 年間はそういう風に
このジャナパダカリャーニということは同じ意味なんですね
その国 その国のその美人ということで
私はそういう 現代風にちょっとアレンジします
そうでないとちょっと理解できません
私はミスジャパンと結婚するんだということと同じことなんですね
そういうふうに私はこういう美人と結婚するんだと
ああ そう その人どこにいるんですかと
わかりませんと そんな人いるんですか？といういるかどうかもわかりませんと
シャトリアですか バラモンカーストですか？ワイシャカーストですか？シュードラのカーストの人です
知ってます 時代も知りませんと
だからあなたはね 何の根拠もないくだらないことを言ってるだけやと
何かするならば探せるでしょうに
例えばこの美人がバラモンカーストやと言ったら
東いるか西いるかわからなくても
片っ端からバラモンカーストの女の人を調べてみれば見つかるでしょうし
無理かもしれませんだけど
一応論理的に可能性ぐらいでもありますね
例えばこの海岸に海岸に純金の砂が一粒ありますよと言ったら
それでもいいんです 論理的に成り立つんです
どこの海岸と言ってないんです
それでも論理的には探すことは可能なんです
論理的にある人がもう片っ端からの世の地球上にある海岸を全部 1粒1粒砂を調べれば調べれば
その純金の砂の 1粒見つかる可能性はありますね
だから方法論は成り立ちます
実践的に可能か不可能かは置いておいて
お釈迦様が言うのは それでもないんだと
あんたがということは
それぐらいにも探す方法はないんだと
ですからそこはこのヨーロッパで
このイギリスで この なんとか哲学派が生まれたんですね
この彼らよく言うのはミーニングレス
ミーニングフルという言葉で
何哲学者でしたっけ？もう随分昔の話
勉強だからもう忘れちゃった
あの哲学者は最近のベルヌーラスもそれに入っちゃうし
もう何人かの有名な人々を作った考え方なんですね
あの まあ言葉には意味があるかないか
意味があるかないかということを調べる
だからそのもう最近はやっているものなんですけど
お釈迦様もその立場で昔もよく喋っていたんですね
言うことには何も 何といいますか
土台も根拠も何もなく
ただ口先だけ 言葉だけで言うということで
それはとにかくみんな問題を起こしたのは
アートマン実体あるということで
まず決めて それに方法を探す
それ見つかる方法 探す前には仮定作る前に
仮説作る前にはそれなりの何か探すための根拠やら方法やら必要なんですね
それはなかったと それでお釈迦様のやり方っていうのは
私たちは何を知ってますか？何を経験していますかと
私たちのすべての知識
智慧が どのように生まれるか
我々は何を知っているかということで
そこにその状態は何ですかと言えば
ずっと変化するんだから成り立つんだと
それで必然的な結論として無我ですよということを成り立つんです
成り立つんですね そういうわけで
お釈迦様はそこでまた実戦的になって無我論だよということを言わないんです
無常だよというところでまた止まるんです
無常から先に自分で言ってくださいと
で まあ一旦もう 1時間ちょうど経過しましたので
私は疲れてませんだけど
まだ話し始めてないんだから
ちょっと 5分ぐらいお休みをいただいて取ってください
ということで この人間が頭で想像した
どこにあるかわからない我についていろいろ困ったり考えたりした時代で
お釈迦様は我というものはどういうものかと
また具体的に明確に再び考えてあげたということで
無我論の部に入ります
で 一番最初に私に自我があるんだという場合は
この私という問題が大事なんですね
私に魂があるんだと 私に何か私たる実体があるんだというふうに言っているんですね
世の中 そこでヨーガやら瞑想やらする人々も
この私たるものを発見しようと頑張っているんですね
で そういうこれインドの文化で
違う世界にしたっても
私には魂があるんだということでもう決めつけて発見しなくてもあるんだから
もうインド人はやっぱり体験しましょうということはあったんだけど
インド以外の世界では別にあるんだから
もういいんじゃないかと
それぐらいで ということで
死んだら魂はもうもう永遠になりますからということで
まあもう落ち着いているんですね
まあ頑張ろうということはないんです
まあそこで でお釈迦様
じゃあ私はって何ですかと
まず私に魂があるということじゃなくて
私は私という 我々言うそのものが客観的に見てみようと
というと お釈迦様はこの 5つに分けちゃうんですね
で この体を 5つに分ける
ルーパ レーダナ サンニャ
サンカーラ ヴィンヤーナ
まあ決まってる 仏教用語ありますけど
また言葉を入れちゃったら
ちょっと 問題起こりますので
それは後で考えましょう
これはだいたいこの人間の体を分けていることで
それでお釈迦様はものすごい分類的にはもうノウハウが持っていて
分類することはね これ異常なものあるんだったら言ってくれという状態なんです
この 5つは誰にでもまた経験できるものなんですね
ルーパ ヴェーダナ サンニャ
サンカーラ ヴィンヤーナという 5つで
この私というそのものができているんだと
じゃあそれから説明に行きます
あまり時間がない たくさんことありますからね
ルーパって何ですかというと
まあこの体なんですね
物体としての体 それたちは誰にでもわかります
体という この物体 この機械
の細胞でできている このものがルーパというんですね
で そこでまあそこで問題解決しておきましょう
この体っていうのは 体に何か体たる実体がありますかと
この現代知識から見ても
我々よくわかっていることで
我々は一個の細胞からスタートするんだけど
その細胞は分裂して今の体ができているんですね
それでその ずっと同じ細胞で生きてるんですかね
そういうわけじゃないんですね
その それぞれ一個の細胞にはあまり長い寿命はないんです
私ははっきりとはわかりませんだけど
おそらく 3ヶ月とかぐらいだろうと思いますけどね
そこら辺は皆様の知識で正しい日にちを理解してください
あまりそこら辺は勉強してないんです
一応仮に 3ヶ月間と言いましょう
で 細胞が 3ヶ月間いちゃったら
それ死んでしまっちゃうんですね
その代わりに新しいものが生まれてくる
で そこで生きているということになる
今も細胞が死んでいく
その代わりに新しい細胞が生まれる
その新しい細胞を作る材料はどこから取るんですかね
0.1ミリグラムとは言えないんですね
初めの細胞っていうのは
ほんの小さいものが今なキロ単位で計算してるでしょうね
50 キロや 60 キロやとかに
それぐらい重さが出たのはどこから出たんですかね
ずっと外の中 外にある物質が入って
新しいシステムを作って
それまたその物質は出ていく
それで母親のお腹の中で生まれた細胞は
とっくにお腹の中でもう死んじゃったんです
後からもうできた母親の体から入ってきた栄養やら
そういうものから材料を取って作った細胞の塊が生まれるんでしょうし
それまたみるみるうちに体が新しく新しく変わっていくんですね
これで細胞の次元から考えたっても
この体には何も変化しないものはない
これはもう原子単位で考えたっても
変化しないものは何もない
ずっと変化していく いわゆる自我
はない お釈迦様は簡単に聞くのはあなたの体
それは変化しますか？変化しないかと質問するんです
ニッチャンはアニッチャンはと
パーリのちゃんとお釈迦様の言葉
ルーパン ビッカレ ニッチャンはアニッチャンは
ルーパンというものは比丘たち
比くらよ ニッチャン永遠かアニッチャン無常か
いつでもお釈迦様は聞く
ただ それすごい簡単なんです
ニッチャン は アニッチャンは
これは質問なんです  1行に書かなきゃいけないんです
もしパーリ語も覚えておきたいと
お釈迦様の言葉その通りに覚えておきたいならば
全部書いておきます ルーパン
ビッカレ ビッカレっていうのは呼ぶ言葉
ルーパン ルーパはビッカレ
ビクラよと呼ぶんです
ニッチャンは永遠か？アニッチャンは無常か
ニッチャっていうのは変化しないもの
永遠なもの アニッチャというのは否定形ですね
日本語になると言葉が逆になっちゃいますけどね
変化するものか 変化しないものか
なんかニッチャっていうのは
まあまあ言葉ない まあ無常から言えば常住か無常かというふうなことでね
だからルーパン ビッカレ
ニッチャンはアニッチャンは
聞いたら当然出てくる答えは何ですかね？この体が変化しますか？変化しないかと聞けば
当然それには誰でもあっという間で答えなくちゃいけないことは
ニッチャンアニッチャンという答えなんですね
アニッチャン お釈迦様が言う場合は
またバンテアニッチャンバンテ
会話形式だからやっぱり人を呼ぶ
で この同じパーリの言葉からこちらはこちらにもつなげますからね
ルーパというものは 本当はこちらはこんなもの入りますけどね
上なんかこれ私が書いたものじゃない
これ何とキスマークみたい
点は下に入ります この体
この個体 この物体は 常か無常かでもいいんですけど
まあ永久的に変化しないものか変化するものですかと聞いたら
答えは変化するものですよと
そこで変化するものはもう評価する場合は
まあ変化するんだから
何の意味もないってことで無効ですよと
じゃあ変化するものは実体ですか？と
変化しないものの中に変化するもののなか
変化するものが変化しないものですかと聞いてことと同じなんです
ですから アッタンでアッタンは聞かない
その場合は じゃあ無常であるならば
あなたはどう思いますか？このルーパ自体が
その体 物体自体がタマアーマンだと我だと観察することは正しいかないかと
正しくないんだ 理屈は簡単です
無常たるものは無常でないと考えることは正しいかということを聞いているんです
体が無常でしょ 無常たるこの体が無常じゃないと考えることは正しいかないかと
したら正しくないんだと
ですから パーリ語で言えば
あのカルアンタンサムヤダニッチャンタン
ドッカンとヤンドッカン
カルアンヌタン サマニ
パス サマナー パスとエソーハマスミ
エソーメアッタという
ちょっと文章が長いんですけど
そちらのものすごい このウパニシャッドの世界で哲学者が考えた同じ言葉を借りて言ってるんですね
無常たるこのルーパが私ですよと
私の我ですよと と考えることは正しいかと
と聞いたら正しくないんだと
それでお釈迦様は最後に
じゃあ無常であるならば
ドッカであるならば 苦であるならば
まだ実体ではないんだから
捨てましょう 持っていく必要ないでしょ
それに対するあなたの未練
希望 欲望 じゃあ全部捨てましょうと
それでそれが終わります
同じように次々から続きます
次にヴェーダナ ヴェーダナっていうのは
あの ただあの そこは一番大事なポイントで
あの物体というならば
私も物体であって この机も物体なんですね
椅子も物体なんですね
この建物は物体なんですね
物体として見ると別になんの差もないんです
でも私と机は本当に同じかというと同じじゃないんですね
私はご飯食べてるんだからね
机は全然食べてないしね
ですから やっぱり違うんですね
何か違う この何か違うところをみんな誤解するんですね
そこでこの何か違うところは次々から説明するんです
私と机と一番違うところはヴェーダナ
感じること 感覚 ヴェーダナっていうのは感じること
感覚のことなんですね
で 建物は何も感じないんです
机も何も感じない で 私は感じちゃうんですね
寒さ感じる 熱さ感じる
何か触れたらすぐわかるんですね
その感じるという働きがあるんです
じゃあ次にそれについて聞くんです
その感じることが変化しないか
変化しますかと ものすごいわかりやすい質問なんです
あなたは感じることは変化するか変化しないかと
感じるということは これ
体より早く変化するんです
で 私の体がね もう一応変化はしていますけど
そんなに見える変化がないでしょう
もうもう 1ヶ月間ぐらいでも立てないと
今日ご飯食べなかったんだからとサッと痩せることはないんだから
やっぱり 2日  3日  4 日間ご飯食べないでいると
もうゆっくり痩せてきますからね
そんなものじゃない 感じるということは
寒い空気が入るとすぐもう寒いと
暖かい空気触れた瞬間に暖かいと
瞬時に変わるでしょう
で 瞑想する時でも座っているとすごく足が痛くてとかね
立った瞬間にもう変わっちゃうでしょうに
だからこのヴェーダナ
感じることは変化するものか
変化しないものかと聞くところは
当然な答えは変化するものやと
それで変化するものだから
それすごいありがたい私ものやと捕まるべきかと
何か気持ちよかったと
それずっとそのままあるんですかね
気持ちよかった瞬間に変化するんだから
だから それもドゥッカであって無我ですよと
もう感覚自体は当然無我ですよっていうのをはっきりと言っておきます
お釈迦様は 変化するんだから実体はない
実体ないでしょう 例えば私の手でこうやって触るとの感覚と
何か針でも持ってきて同じところを触るときの感覚は違うでしょうに
だからその原因によって感覚が変わりますから
気持ちいいか悪いかっていうことは
ですからすごく無常でありまして
原因によって生まれるのであって
実体はない 魂はとにかく感覚にはないと
ときに それなんでそんなことを言いますかというと
この感じることは魂やと言っている人がいるんです
いたんです 今もいるんですけど
それでお釈迦様はそれはそうじゃないかと
別に否定しているということじゃなくて
ただどうですかね 客観的に見れば
ただそれだけ ですから
お釈迦様のキーワードですと無常から始まるんです
その感覚自体がどうですかね
無常かそうでないかと
変化しないか 変化するかと
変化はするんだと じゃあ変化するんだったら実体大円だとは言えますかねと
それは言えませんと それでヴェーダナ同じく無我であると決めちゃう
決められる 決めるしか道がないんです
次にサンニャーということ
サンニャーっていうのは
この まあ私はこの うんと理解しやすくするために
我々のこの知識みたいなもんだと
と覚えておいてください
この厳密にアビダンマ的に解釈しちゃうと
ものすごいややこしくてわからなくなりますから
簡単にわからなきゃまた意味がないんですね
で 私たちにはもういっぱい知識ようなものがあるんですね
この知識というのは 私は勉強していないんだから知識がないんだというのは
それは嘘であって 知識がなければ生きていられないんです
犬にもありますから だから私たちにはないと言ったっても
私は聞きません そんな話は
犬にもミミズにもあります
知識は どういうことかというと
ミミズは何を食うべきか
何を食べてはいけないかを知っているんだから
どこに穴を掘ってばいいかと知ってるでしょうに
それは知識なんです これはバラの花だ
これは桜の花だという
そういう区別できる能力
それは知識なんです そこで勉強する人々はさらに区別できる能力が増えるだけ
役に立たないんだけど
ですから この知識というものはミミズにもあるんだから
アメーバにもありますからね
ないとは言えません それはサンニャーというんです
だから知識には違う言葉があります
言葉をもって操っている知識には
仏教では別な言葉を使ってますけど
ですからこれはもう生命の基本だから
その言葉を使わない サンニャー
だからだいたいサンニャーお分かりになると思いますけどね
だからミミズさえもアメーバさえも生きている場合は
自分使っている そのノウハウ
それにサンニャーと呼ぶんです
それで問題は そのサンニャー自体が変化するかしないかということ
どうですかね 我々はこのノウハウを持っているノウハウというか知識というか
生きている生き続けるために我々使っている
そのエネルギーが変化しますかしないかと
当時の人は当然あれは変化しますよと
わかります どうしてもわからないというならば
なんで勉強するんですかね
勉強すると何が成長するんですかね
サンニャーが成長するんです
区別判断できる能力が
分別判断できる能力が成長するだけのことで
英語を勉強するんだと言ったっても
ただ音を聞いたら違う感覚を作るということだけでしょうに
その立場で英語を勉強してください
早く勉強できるんです
グッドモーニングという言葉は辞書を引いてグッドって何ですか？と
モーニングと何ですかとかね
それで勉強できないんです
例えばおはようございますという時のその言葉
音 その音について おはようございますという音についてどんな感覚かと
じゃあグッドモーニングと言ったらもう同じかと
音を入れ替えれば同じことです
ペンシルと言ったっても鉛筆と言ったっても
ただ音は違うだけで ものは同じものなんです
だからこのサンニャーの立場から勉強しちゃうと
随分早く語学は勉強できるんです
なぜならば 人間というのはもう感じることみんな同じ
ほとんど同じだから 自分を産んだ人についてある感じが誰でも同じことでしょうに
それにファーザーマザーというか
お母さんというか お袋
おふくろさんとなんとか言うか
どうでもそれもう同じことだと
じゃあサンニャーが変化するということはそこでわかりますね
いろんなことを勉強すると
我々のサンニャーの世界が変わるでしょうに
変わらなきゃ勉強できない
サンニャーが変わらなきゃ
もう全然どんな言葉を聞いたっても
まるっきり何の変化もないはずなんです
それでサンニャー自体が無常であることはわかります
そこだけじゃない そうすると増えるばっかりではないかと
そこはありがたい話なんですね
勉強すればするほど増えるばっかり
増えるばかり 減るんです
増えると同時に減ってもいくんです
勉強したものは忘れちゃうし
あまりにも減りすぎて
もうね もう年取ってところで
時々年取らなくてもね
アルツハイマーになっちゃったら
みるみるうちにサンニャーがなくなっちゃうでしょうに
そこで自分の大便も食べてしまうでしょ
持ってるサンニャーは食べ物というサンニャーだけ
で 見たものは食べ物やと勘違いするんです
実際は自分の大便かもしれません
何のことなく食べる で
ボケてる人に何か紙でも絵はがきでも見せちゃったら
何のことなくつぶって食べると
あるでしょ で 私たちはああだこうだとか何言ったっても
別に何のこともなく 無常だから
サンニャーが その方に残っているサンニャーはただそれだけ
生きるためには食べるってこと必要だから
なんかそれだけ残っている
もしそのボケてる人の場合は
先に食べるというサンニャーが消えちゃったら
その人食べないんです
なんも体いくら痩せても飢え死になっても食べなくなっちゃうんです
食べるというサンニャーが消えちゃったら
食べ物というサンニャーが消えちゃったら
だいたいはこの基本的なサンニャーっていうのは
まあ結構続けていくんです
そういうことで サンニャーは変化するかしないかと聞いたら
それは変化する みるみるうちに変化する
どれぐらい変化するかというと
私は一生懸命今喋ってるんだ
出たけど 全部忘れちゃうでしょうね
全部テーラワーダのせいにする
簡単に忘れちゃうんです
だからまあ だからこのサンニャー忘れ
忘れるスピードが遅い人はよく勉強できる人だったと
強烈な勢いで忘れる人には勉強できないんだと
いくら教えたっても あなたはダメやと言うんですね
それは別に教える時はその人は理解するんです
理解はするんだけど もう立ったらもう終わりと
お釈迦様はある経典でこう言うんですね
いろんな人がいるんだと言って
ある人がこのこれ その人の智慧がこの膝の上に荷物
膝の上に物を置くことと同じだと
膝の上に物が置くと 立っちゃったら全部落ちちゃうでしょうし
そういうふうに一生懸命説法を聞いたっても
立ったら忘れますよと
そういう人もいるんだと
それでもう一人がいて
このザルに水を汲むような人やと
ザルザルでザルでザルに水を入れることと同じだと
いくら入れてもそうと
その瞬間で取っていってしまっちゃうと
それは知識の世界 それも知識と同じ
サンニャー同じなんですけどね
ですからサンニャーっていうのは当然変化するものです
そこに実体がありますかと
例えば これはバラの花だよと分別する
私の機能に分別できるその機能に実体があるかというと
そこの実体がないでしょうし
ですからサンニャーは無我である
次にサンカーラ これ複数形でサンカーラ
これは一つ これは一つ
働きとしては感じることは一つ
サンニャーは一つ 分別判断の能力だから
サンカーラはたくさんあります
サンカーラっていうのは
この私はこの最近このいろいろ研究して
本を書いたお坊さんのテキストから
それわかりやすいんだから言いますけど
人間の心の中でこのいつでもあるんですね
なんかもうエネルギーがあるんで
なんかやらなくちゃというエネルギー
この何かやらなくちゃというエネルギーは
生きていけ生きていかなくちゃという同じ気持ちなんですね
それですーっと人間動いてるんです
ご飯作るはご飯食べるは
服を洗うは 服は着るは寝るは歩くは仕事をするは
もういろんなことをやっているんです
瞬間も止まりません 何かやらなくちゃという気持ちはずっとあるんです
それ なくなったら死んじゃうんです
で 呼吸さえ吸ったら吐かない
吐かなくちゃと 吐いたら吸わなくちゃということで成り立ってるんです
だからこの呼吸瞑想をずっとさせると
それよくわかるんです
吸ったところで吐きたくなる
吐いたところで吸いたくなる
だから止めることなく吸ったり吐いたりしている
ご飯を食べると止めやめたくなる
それからまた食べたくなる
それでまた食べる それまたやめたくなると
そういうふうにいつでも何かしたくなる
食べたくなる やめたくなる
それをストップしたらどうなるんですかね
食べたくなる それはずっと永久的にあるんだと言えば
その人は食べる 食べる
食べる 終わらないでしょうに
死んじゃうんです そういう生きるものに
生きているものに すべての生きている生命に
この生きるということは
何かしなくちゃという
その気持ちなんです それは今の人間にはすごいすごいことで
なんかやることをなければ怖くてたまらなくなっちゃうんです
退屈でやることないと
たまらなくなるんです
だからいっぱい仕事をわざと作るんです
例えば休みだったら 休みの時は何をしますか？しますかと
また決めるんです 計画
スケジュールを作るんです
作ってそれをやるんです
何もやることないともう趣味でも作ってそれをやっているんですね
やっぱり何かやるということは生きるということで
やることを少なくなると生きる元気が少なくなる
当然のことです すごく退屈になって
あまりにもやることがなくなってしまうと鬱でしょうね
それで自殺しちゃうんですね
でも自殺したいということもやりたいということなんです
結局抜けられないサンカーラからは
世間のことで何もやることはないと
面白くないと 部屋から出たくないんだと
人と喋りたくないんだと
言って パジャマのまんまで 1 日中いるとかね
それであまりにも退屈で
また何かやりたくなる
やりたくなるで自殺もするということ
どう見たってもやりたくなるということだけは
生命にはもうずっとある
それは消えない まあ消えないであるんだけど
問題はそれは変化しますか
変化しないかということなんです
どうですかね すぐ変化するでしょうに
その場にその場において
瞬時に変化する やりたいということ
例えば映画見たいと思ったりする
それでそこまで行く 行ったところで今日は休館だと
じゃあ帰ってお茶でも飲もうとなっちゃうんでしょうに
瞬時に変わる やりたいことは
だから この生きる衝動としてのサンカーラなんですけど
それはもういつ瞬時に
瞬時に 瞬時に変わって変わっていくんです
それは人々が魂だと誤解している場合もありますね
私には神様に決められた試練があるんだとかね
人間はここで生まれたのは何か目的があるあるんであることで生まれたんだとかね
ああいうのはもういい加減な根拠ない
ただの言葉の遊びなんですね
そんなに試練があるならば何ですか？と聞いたらわからないでしょうに
なんであなたは生まれたんですか？と聞いたらわかるんですかね
どんな人間の誰でもわかってないでしょうに
ただやりたいんだから
何かやってる途中で勘違いするんです
ヒトラーさんみたいに
まあどうもじっとしていられない精神的な病気で
そのヒトラーですか アドルフ
アドルフ・ヒトラーという人がね
そうすると その人がいろいろやっているところで
人を抑えるは殺すはいろんなことをやって
どんどんどんどんやって
刺激が出てきて 私はもう選ばれているんだと
いうことだけであって
選ばれているか もう死んじゃったんだからね
そういうのは嘘でしょうし
だから私には何かやるべき仕事があるんだとかいうのは
やっぱり同じことで いろんなことをやっていると
あれはなんかやらなくちゃいけないという気持ち
いつでもありますからね
だからやっぱりやるべき仕事はあるんだと思い勘違いするだけ
やるべき仕事あるんじゃなくて
なんかやらなくちゃいけないという気持ちがあるんだと
それは何ですかと 私もわかりませんと
やりたいのは私ですけど
何がやりたいかとわからないというのは事実なんです
それでその周りにある何かやってるんです
山の中で生まれて山の中で育った人間だったら
そこら辺でいる 何かやってるんです
東京で生まれ 東京で育った人は
そこら辺で何かやってるんです
それでとにかく人間の生命の心の中に
何かやらなくちゃという気持ちがあるんです
それは人間の哲学と違うところは
これ生命の論理だから
アメーバにもあることなんです
アメーバも何かやらなくちゃという気持ちがあるんだだからこそ
ちょっと先に進まなくちゃいけないと
この餌を食わなくちゃいけないという気持ちはあるんです
言葉じゃないんです 分裂しなくちゃという気持ちがなければ分裂しませんでしょうし
生きていられないんです
それサンカーラがなければ
そこでアメーバには微かなんですけど
人間にはすごいいろんなことがある
人間がわざと強引に作ったサンカーラがいっぱいありますね
建物を作らなくちゃとかね
経済活動しなくちゃとかね
原子爆弾作らなくちゃとかね
いろんなもうサンカーラが生まれてくる
そこでそのやりたがるエネルギーなんですね
それにもたくさんあります
それから私たちの生まれる怒りやら嫉妬やら慈しみやら
そういう感情をサンカーラに入っちゃうんですね
そういうものを生まれたっても
やっぱり何かやりたくなっちゃうんですね
嫉妬が生まれたら何か何かやりたくなる
怒りが生まれたら何かやりたくなる
慈しみの気持ちが生まれあっても
何かやりたくなるということで
全部一つにまとめられます
だから 人間の一般的に我々知っている感情と
このやりたいやりたいという気持ちをまとめてサンカーラと言うんです
たくさんあります で 人間にはたくさんあるんだけど
犬にもあります 犬にあるサンカーラと私が持っているサンカーラはまるっきり同一ものやって
それは違うんです でも質としては同じ
犬には 100あるならば
人間には 1億あるかもしれません
ただそれだけ サンカーラに変わりがない
そこでそのサンカーラは
お釈迦様のまた前の質問
サンカーラビッケはニッチャンはアニッチャンは
サンカーラというものはニッチですか？変化しないか
アニッチャン あるいは変化しますかと
答えは決まってて変化するでしょうに
みるみるうちに変化するでしょうに
ここでケーキと座って見たところで
あ 食べたいと気持ち生まれるでしょうね
食べたいと思う 私は本当は私は舐めたんですよと
舐めてみたんだけど 美味しかったよと言ったら
どんな気持ちで その場合は
ああ 嫌ですよ 食べたくないという気持ち
サンカーラが生まれる
瞬時に原因変わったんだから
条件変わったんだから
まあそれよりももっとひどい例えで言っちゃいます
もう僕はこれ試したことなんですけど
でもある人になんかたいものをどこで買ったの？いえ
そこから拾ってきたんですよと言ったら
食べないです まあバカだからアホでしょ
そんな人に拾ってきたものはもうあげるわけじゃないし
どうせ正真正銘のこれ買ってきてものってわかってるんで
人間ってのは本当にどこへもどこまで愚かっていうこともありますけど
それは私の個人的な楽しみで
もう拾ってきた 食べ食べなかったんですね
食べないと僕は怒ってね
あんた本当に何で馬鹿者かと
もうちょっと合理的に考えてくださいと
だからそのサンカーラっていうのはそんなもんで
もうほんのちょっとのことで変化する
だからサンカーラ自体
何かやりたいという この我々の心の中である
このずっとある この感じが魂じゃない
自我ではない 実体ではない
勘違いするのは気持ちはわかります
ずっとあるんだから やりたい
生きたいという気持ちがずっとあるんだから
魂だと勘違いするのは気持ちはわかるんだけど
ちょっと見ると合理的に
これすごい強烈な勢いで変化する
ですから サンカーラも無我である
そこで最後にヴィンヤーナが出てきます
ヴィンヤーナっていうのは
このまあまあ簡単な言葉で言えば心というものなんですけど
それでもわからないと思いますから
こういう風に このこの机と私が違うでしょ
このどこで違うかというと
その私に心という認識する働きがあるんですね
認識するという外の世界
机と私の違うところ ただそれだけ
私はもう外の世界あると知っている
机は知らない その働きでヴィンヤーナというんです
心ですね 認識 識ですね
仏教用語では識というんです
認識の識 だからそこも永久的にあるかというとそうじゃないと
だって人が死ぬのは当然見えるでしょうに
そこで認識することは止まるでしょうし
それでも心は無常ということは見えるし
その認識するということはなぜ無常かというと
バラの花認識する 全く同じ心でご飯は認識できないんです
そうすると バラの花見たってのも
ご飯見たってのもバラの花に見える可能性あります
認識することは心だから
だから これすごい無常なんです
建物を見たら建物やと認識する
椅子見たら椅子だと認識する
同じ認識だったら 建物見たっても同じものを
椅子を見たっても同じものになってしまっちゃうんです
ですから 区別判断はできなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 心っていうのはずっと変化します
それでもわからないんだったらね
やっぱりあなた方の心は変わりませんか？と
見てくださいと 変わるでしょうに
この人と一生生活しますよと思っても
もう 1年で  2年でもうじゃあやめますということになるでしょうに
心を見る見るうちに変わってしまっちゃう
ですから 心というものも
色というものも無常であって
だから無我であると決めるんですね
で 次 そういうわけで 私というものがお釈迦様
５つに分ける その分け方の不思議なことっていうのは
それは人間の体の分析ではありません
一切の生命はそういうふうに成り立っているということ
人間だけではない 神々もこの 5つ持ってるんです
だからミミズとアメーバと私たちの体を持ってるんだけど
体それぞれ違うでしょうし
そのように神であろうが
もっと上の生命であろうか
幽霊であろうか 誰であろう
関係ないんだけど やっぱりそれなりにこの 5つがあるんです
だから誰にあったっても
これは基本的な働きだから
それは無常ですよと 無常の塊ですよ
だからそこには我が見つかりませんと
体の中では 体の中を見つからなかったら
それで終わりでしょ 問題は
それ時々馬鹿者が体の外で探すんだとやっちゃうんです
自分の中に魂がなければ
それで問題は終わりますけど
外にあるんじゃないかなと
それにもお釈迦様は違う経典で説明しちゃうんです
こういう例えばルーパはニッチャかアニッチャかと聞いて
永遠か変化するかと聞いて
変化しないと 変化しないものはドッカかないかでドッカですよと
ドッカたるものは無我ですか？我ですか？と言われたら無我ですよとお坊さんたちが答えるんです
そこでお釈迦様は言うんです
だから過去であろうか
ルーパはルーパだから
現在のルーパもルーパだから
未来のルーパもルーパだから
内のルーパもルーパだから
外の世界のルーパもルーパだから
ルーパは無我ですよと
簡単でしょ 論理は だから外にも探すのはバカバカらしいんですね
私には真我がないんだけど
神様に真我があるんだとかいうのは
もう全く仏教から見ればもう無意味なもう話なんですね
ルーパの立場から考えちゃうと
こちらにルーパがあって
それは無常で無我ですよ
いや わかったと だから
こちらにあるもルーパでしょうに
あちらにあるもルーパでしょうに
だから過去であろうか
未来であろうか 現在であろうか
ここに中のものであろうか
外のものであろうか 遠いものであれば近いもの
いろんな言葉を使って
ヤンドゥーレ ヤンサンティケ
ヤンヒーナン ヤンパニタン
ヤンスクマンとか あるいはすっごい微細な微細なきめ細かいものであろうか
ルーパだから あるいは大きな地球みたいに
太陽みたいに 宇宙みたいな巨大なものである
ルーパでしょ 結局は物質でしょ
ということで きれいさっぱり我を否定するんです
と同じことをヴェーダナサンニャサンカルンニャーにも言うんです
そういうふうに無我っていうのは
じわじわと無我の理解に行かなくちゃいけない
そこでもう一つも時間が終わりましたけど
お釈迦様こう言うんですね
もしルーパの中でこれというくらい
ほんのこのほんのちょっとでもということは
現代的に言えば このまあそれぐらいでも
無常なもの 無常でないもの
自我であるものあるならば
私はあなた方に解脱しなさいと言いません
と で ヴェーダナサンニャサンカルンニャーも同じこと言うんです
それぐらい明確に無我だよと言ってるんですけど
そうじゃないという人々はいるんです
素晴らしい 国際的なすごい有名なまあ学者の方々も言ってはいるんですけどね
それはもう勉強足らないということで
学者に限って勉強しませんだからね
で まあそういうことで
お釈迦様はもう綺麗にこの人は五蘊にこの５つに分けたこと自体で
この世の中の全ての哲学に応えているんです
神様は私は作ったか 自然に現れたかとかね
あるいは人間は偶然に生まれたかとか
いろんなことを話あるでしょうに
生命誕生 偶然だ 全部に応えているので
まあとにかくこの５つですよと
そこに神は成り立たなくなるんですから
それで十分だよ お釈迦様にとっては
私は頭が悪いんだから
神はありませんといませんと
言うと 神を信じている人々にはすごく失礼なことを言われたことになりますけど
けど お釈迦様はまあ人っていうのはこういう５つでしょうということで
もう何のことなく あの考え方はもう相手にしていない
で もう一つワンステップ進む言うならば
人間はこの全てのものは認識して理解して喋っているでしょうし
たとえ神がいる 魂がある
私は永遠なものやということも
その人間の理解なんですね
それは確かなんです 理解していないものは喋れないでしょうに
考えていないものは喋れないでしょうに
だから人間喋っている
考えている全ては人間の理解で経験であります
それはものすごい究極的な瞑想をしている
もうすごい昔のいた仙人たちであろうか
自分たちが感じたものを喋っているんです
ブラフマンがいるんだとか
あるいはあの念仏なんか唱えると
真面目に頑張ってね もう阿弥陀様が現れてくるんだという話もあるしね
そういうのはその本人が正直なものでだと仮定すると
まあほとんど正直もない場合もありますけど
正直なものだと仮定して考えると
その人には見えたものなんです
阿弥陀様が見えたという
そういうふうに人間が語っている
宗教 哲学を始めてからあるすべてのもの
神がいるということも
神がいないということも
阿弥陀様がいるということもいないということも
仏教は正しいということも
正しくないということも
どっちでも人間の理解でありますね
それにもあまり異論ないでしょ
うん じゃあそれから言ってみましょう
人間が物事をどのように理解するかと
そこでこれ五蘊ですから
皆様知ってますね 色受想行識という日本語の言葉
人間はどのように物事を理解するかというと
こういうチャック ソース
ガーナ ジューター あれ
マナという  ６種類の働きが体にあるんです
チャックは目 ソータは耳
ガーナは嗅覚 鼻 ジューハは舌
味の味覚 味覚 彼は体ですね
体の外側と内側の感覚ですね
体のマナっていうのは人間の意識ですね
心 それ以外 我々に情報が入る方法ありますか？その体に情報が入る窓口でしょ
そこで全ての生命にはこんなもんです
ミミズには目がないんだけど
アメーバの目も耳もないんだけど
体があるんですね  ２つぐらいあります
体とこの判断できるんだから
意識っていうのはあるんです
人間には ６つ揃っている
7番目はない ありえないんです
だからこれ 6つも揃っているか
一つ二つ抜けているかということはありますが
大体一切の生命にあるのは眼耳鼻舌身意というその 6つなんです
そこを分析して考えちゃうと
発見できることは何でしょうかね
チャック自体は無常でありますね
もう問題ない 目自体が
だからそれは無我なんです
で 同時に耳も無我でしょうし
変化するでしょうし 鼻も変化するでしょうし
舌のもうもう変化は当たり前
わかっていることだから
体も変化することも体の感もわかっているでしょうし
心は瞬時に変化するということはまたわかっている
わかってなければ理解してください
で そういうのは変化する
ですから この 6つはもう無常であって
苦であって無我でありますと
それで不思議なこと 目に何を触れるかというと
チャックにはルーパという形が触れるでしょうに
耳にはサッドという 音が触れるでしょうに
鼻にはガンダという 香りが触れるでしょうに
一応専門用語は書いておきます
そうやって入る情報 また決まっている
目には形しか入らない
耳には音しか入りませんし
あの 仏教用語では これは眼耳鼻舌身意であって
これは色声香味触法という六根ですからね
まあ大体わかってらっしゃるだろうと思います
耳にはサッだけしか聞こえない
音しか聞こえない 鼻には香りしか認識できません
そういうわけでわからないのはこのマナとダンマなんですね
で マナっていうのは心自体で
外から情報なくても 我々は頭の中でいろんなことを考えてるでしょ
それはマナとダンマなんですね
考える時でも何かについて考えるでしょ
ですから 考える時は対象があるんです
昨日食べたご飯についていた
今考えているんだと 瞑想すると思って
みんなそれですよ やっているのは
瞑想を置いておいて いろんなことを考えて妄想したりしている
その時でもいつでも何かについて考えているでしょ
何かについてでなければ考えられませんだから
だからその考えるものの対象はダンマというんですね
もうダンマの日本語訳は法なんですけど
それはちょっとややこしい言葉で
もう大雑把でも使えます
真理という意味でも使っちゃうし
法教えという言葉で使っちゃうし
現象という言葉でも使うし
まあそういうふうにまあ大雑把でも使います
ですから なかなかこのまあ説明しにくくなってますけど
でも意味はわかりやすい
頭で考えるものなんですね
昨日食べたご飯について考える
だから昨日食べたご飯いる
ある必要ないんです だからあるものを考えられる
この建物の色はなんでしょうかとかね
これはおそらく黄色い
白い いえ 白いじゃないな
ちょっと黄色っぽいだからクリーム色かな
クリーム色とも言いにくいと
いくらでも考えられるでしょうに
今あるものについて考えている
そこでこれを作る前にどんな建物でしたかなとか考えられるでしょ
おそらくこれを作って今 20年とやっているんだから
おそらく古い日本風なお寺でしたでしょうとかね
瓦の屋根でしたでしょう
おそらくとかね これ鉄筋コンクリートだから
やっぱり屋根はどうか
瓦じゃない とにかく ですから
現在あるものについても考えられる
もう今ないものについても考えられる
だから人間に霊魂のことも
魂のことも 神のことも考えられる
だからあるというわけにはならないでしょ
私は考えているんだからあるんだと
で くだらないことも考えてる
だからくだらないこともあるってわけにならないでしょうに
だから私は考える だから私がいる
だから魂があるというのは
もういい加減な言葉であって
考えるんだからといって
ベースにそれは事実かないかっていうのは
何関係ないんです 人間は何でも考えられますから
ですから そう分析すると
我々の知識の世界 この理解の世界っていうのはガタガタと壊れていくはずなんです
人間困ってる 自分がそう考えてるんだからなんてこう考えちゃったら
こういう考え方が浮かんだんだよと
だから何ですか？と 何でも浮かぶんです
頭の中に ある人はこう言うんですね
神様を信じてる人が 私は神の概念を壊しちゃったんで
とにかく壊しちゃって
その代わりにこうやって考えればいいか
あ 私もやっぱり神様はそうじゃなくて
こんな感じだなと思ってるんだよと
で またおかしいことを言うんですね
いわゆるパーソナル God ではないんだ
僕はそれはありえないと
いわゆる法則として見たら
私もやっぱり法則自体が神様だよと思ってるんだいと言ったら
私言うことと全く逆でしょうにと
だから神様がいるだと
あの その話だった人がそう思っちゃうんですね
自分が考えるんだからいるわけじゃないんです
私たちはこちらのこのお寺
この新しい建物を造る前にあった建物のことを考えられるでしょうし
あるいはこれ壊れた時
いつか壊れますから それからどんな建物を作るだろうと考えられるでしょうに
だからその通りになりますか？ならないでしょうし
だから兎の角がないんだけど
兎の角は考えられます
髪の毛がないんだけど
髪の毛は考えられます
想像もできます 絵も描けます
私はすごいこの羊のようにいっぱい毛がついてる亀の絵を描いたとする
それで羊の毛のようにいっぱい毛がついている亀がいるんですかね
いる必要ありますかね
そういうわけで 人間一番引っかかっているのは
この意識の働きなんです
余計なことを考えて考えて
これあると勘違いする
それでお釈迦様の答えが
チャックは変化するかしないか
変化する 見えるものは変化するかしない
変化するでしょ 変化しなきゃ見えませんし
これも耳は変化する 音は変化する
鼻は変化する 香りは変化する
で 舌は変化する それで味は変化するんだから味は得るんだから
そこで体は変化する 体に触れるものは変化する
どっちでも実体が心は常に変化する
心で考えるものはむちゃくちゃ変化するんです
どこに実体があるんですかと
どこに毛があるんですかと
だから我々の感じるすべてのものの中にもないということになるんです
そこで一応無我ということは成立するんです
それ そこだけで止まらないで
お釈迦様は いえ 私は目で物を見て知識が生まれたでしょうと
知ったでしょうと 知ったことは我だと言うんです
ジャイナ教はそういうふうに言うんです
知ることは我ですよ 知ることは変化するでしょう
それでチャックヴィンヤーナがあるんですね
それ全部ヴィンヤーナが入るんです
そうとヴィンヤーナ ガーナ
ヴィンヤーナ ディバ ヴィンヤーナ
カーヴィンヤーナ マノヴィンヤーナ
ヴィンヤーナ これだけでちょっと筋筋筋が変わります
マノヴィンヤーナというわけです
他のものは大体どっちでもかけられると思います
そういうチャックヴィンヤーナ
ソート ヴィンヤーナ で
まあガーナヴィンヤーナディバ
ヴィンヤーナ カーヴィンヤーナ
ヴィンヤーナの識 だからチャックは目ですから
眼識でしょう おそらくこれは相当は耳だからね
耳は知識 知識と読むんです
で それはもう魂永遠じゃないでしょうに
例えば何か目で見る その時のヴィンヤーナが音
耳で聞く それはまた違うヴィンヤーナだから
で 無常ですから それも無常でしょうということで
無我ということは成立するんです
で まあそれ以上は語れないと思います
それ以上何かあるかと
何かあるかというのは
その人知ってることだからですね
この中に入っちゃうんです
私はまるっきり知らないもの
知り得ないものはあるんだというのも
ばからしいでしょうに
それは唯識の阿頼識と同じくなっちゃうんです
だが阿頼識じゃないんです
ん？何？はい あのマノーウィンニャン MANO
それわけで なんでいちいちこんな無我のことをお釈迦様がおっしゃったかというと
またあの花の例に戻って考えてください
もういいなと もうあると思ったところで苦しみが生まれるんだからそれだけ
私がいるんだと思ったら
それそれこそ不幸だと
我があるということ自体は
この世にない一番恐ろしい
不幸な暗い概念なんです
それで人間が一切苦しみを作る
魂があるんだからと思ったら
魂は救わなく救わなくちゃいけないし
なんで魂救ってあげなくちゃいけないんですかね
魂だから救ってあげなくてもいいでしょうに
それで魂が神様のところに行かなくちゃと
で 神様の機嫌を取らなきゃそこに行かないんだと
それで神様の機嫌取れない連中は
どうせ地獄に行くんだから早く行かせてあげようとかね
で 人を殺したりまでしたりとかね
まあそうそう 一切苦しみがこの世の中で起こるのは
単なるこの誤解からなんです
勘違いからなんです 合理的じゃないだからなんです
論理的じゃない 合理的じゃない
科学的じゃない ものは見ない
ですから このセットで仏教の無我論が本当は終了します
で それからもうちょっとまあ蛇足なんですけど
言い過ぎなことはあります
で 無常という無我という
アナッタという言葉がありますね
これ アナッタという言葉にお釈迦様はもう一つ実体はない
という意味でしょう 無我ですよ
もう実体はないということはゼロということなんですね
数学的に考えれば ゼロにはパーリ語でサンスカリット語でシュンニャというんです
パーリ語だったらスンニャ
この言葉は他の言葉にはないんです
中国語でもないんです
だからまあ 育てた言葉です
で 実体はないんだからないということを意味するために
シュンニャという言葉を使うんです
ですから そんなに哲学的な大変な言葉ではないんです
発展するべき言葉ではないんです
それはただないということを言ってる
シュンニャゼロという概念だけですからね
だからそれはあくまでも概念であって
実際に我々の生きることとは関係ない言葉なんです
ゼロは本当にゼロは存在しますかと
例えば数学的に考えちゃうと
ゼロ自体は存在しないでしょうに
でも一応我がないということでゼロと呼ぶんです
ただ ここにリンゴは 2つありますよと言ったところで
じゃあ １個はあの なんとかまあ
田中さんが食べたと どれくらいあります？また 1個ありますと
あ もう 1個は まあ村田さん食べたと
でもありますから ゼロですよ
ゼロがあるわけじゃないんです
あのリンゴ 2つなければ
そこにリンゴゼロという概念が成り立たないんですね
そういうわけで ゼロという概念
シュンニャという概念っていうのは
あの言って無我ですよと言って続けて言うだけ
だから眼耳鼻舌身は無我であるというように空であると
色受想行色 無常ですよと
だから空ですよと だから無我ですよと
だから空ですよと そういうわけでお釈迦様の教えでは
もう何のことなく普通の言葉として空という概念があるんです
そこで全てのものは空であることは理解すれば悟りますよと
そういう言葉も微かにはあるんです
そこでシュンニャ 何もないという単なる言葉だから
お釈迦様はいろんな言葉を使う
チンキローやと 泡だと
現象は泡のごとくだと
幻やと 現象やと 幻想やと
幻想だと そういうのは一般的な言う言葉ですね
そこでやがて仏教で衆妙という
このもうまあどうでもいい
もうまあついでに言った言葉なんですけど
それだけ取って哲学が作っちゃったんです
空論というものが そこからまた大変なことになったんです
またあの行動 行動の哲学は壊れてしまったんです
だから これは余計なであそこですからね
まあ聞いても聞かなくてもいいんですけど
で 仏教はあそこで終わっちゃうんです
どういうことかというと
この犯人が私は見つかってますからね
こういう発展した仏教で
すべての仏教で考えている
尊敬されている 拝んでいる経典の一つあるんです
仏典ではないんです そちらにはルーパは衆妙ですよと言うんです
経典は後で名前を言います
ルーパは衆妙ですよと
ぴったし合ってるでしょ
お釈迦様の言葉に ルーパは無常でしょうし
だから苦であるし 実体はないでしょうし
だから衆妙なんです 確かにお釈迦様がおっしゃったところはあるんです
ルーパンビッカラエソンニャンと
でもその時お釈迦様はゼロという数学には入らないように
スンニャミダンアッテーナはアッペニーナは
このルーパの中には実体自我がないんだからないと言うんだと
衆妙と言うんだと だから自我という無我ということで
そのまま無我 すなわち衆妙ということを言っているんです
そこでルーパは衆妙ですよという言葉もぴったしお釈迦様の教えなんですね
そこでもっと威張ってお釈迦様よりもっと進んでいるではないかと思って
衆妙はルーパですよと言うんです
ルーパは色ですからね
もう経典わかってると思います
色は空であると 次にもっと威張って空はすなわち色ですよと言うんです
威張ったんじゃなくて
もう太鼓を手で叩いたらすごい綺麗な音が
じゃあ上に乗ってジャンプしようと思ったらバレちゃったと
あれ スティックで叩いたらこんなに綺麗な音が出るんだから
俺が自分で飛んだったらもっと綺麗な音が出るかと思ったところで
それ晴れちゃう バレちゃうんですね
これおかしいんです 色即是空
空即是色ってのはおかしいんです
まるっきり勘違いなんです
ルーパはもう実体がないんだからシューニャですけど
シューニャという事態がルーパにならないんです
それで例を言うとわかります
犬は動物である 正しいでしょ
だから動物は犬であると
リンゴは木であると 故に木はリンゴですよと
こんなこと言うアホがいるんでしょうかと思いますけど
でも言ってるんです さらに進んで言うんです
ルーパーナプラタクシューニャタと
皆様はこれ写経したり読んだりするんだけど
原文でわからないでしょ
これはもともとの言葉でこうやって書いてるんです
サンスクリット語で ルーパーナプラタクシューニャタ
ルーパー 色からナプラタ
異なるものではないと
シューニャタっていうのは空は
それはもうその通りです
色というものは空ですから
別に離れてるもの 色自体は空ですよと
そこでまたいばっちゃって逆を言うんですね
シューニャタヤンナプラタルーパ
そこはおかしいと私が言ってるんです
色は無常だから 空であることはね
まあ色そのものが空であるってわかりますけど
空そのものが色ですよというと
あんまりにもおかしいところなんです
そこで私みたいにこの非難しない
批判しないんだから 皆様がよくできてるんだ
人々だから そこに何か大事な意味があるんじゃないかといって
膨大な本があるんです
その経典について 全部間違いです
私から個人的な意見で言えばね
そこで何が間違ってるかというと
この この行目間違ったんだから
あ これ 1番目もサンスクリット語で書いておきましょうか
そうするとルーパン ルーパンシューニャタ
これあの 日本語じゃなくてサンスクリット語で覚えていればかっこいいんです
サンスクリット語でも知ってるんです
シューニャタイワルーパ
ものすごくここで強調するんです
シューニャタ そのものがルーパであると
すごい厳密に強調して言うんです
漢文ではそんなに厳密に強調しているかどうか
ちょっとわかりませんだけど
調べてみます 色即色即是空
空即是色 あ その前に色不異空
空不異色ですね あまりあの
強調の言葉は抜けちゃってるんですね
漢字だから そういうこのちょっと微かなことでそれちゃうと大変なことになるんです
だからこれはまあ私の説明だから
別に認めたっても認めなくても
まあどっちでも全然気にしませんだから
まあ私は持ってきませんだから何も
で 一応あの そういう風になっているんですね
それで問題はこのシューニャタ
空は色でしょ 同時に受想行を全部そうなっちゃうでしょ
そうすると空というものから現象が現れるという誤解が生まれるんです
空があって 空から色が現れる
これ書いてるんだから
シューニャタイワルーパと
不  不異色と漢字で言うならば
ですから そこら辺でいろんな人々がいろんな考え方を発達しちゃったんです
だから空論 正しく語っているのは般若心
般若経 たくさん膨大な量がありますけど
そちらではなくて 般若論語を書いている龍樹さんですね
彼が間違ってないんです
彼にも欠点いっぱい言いたい
言えばいくらでも僕には文句は言えますけど
やっぱりそうじゃなくて
一般的に知識的な哲学的なレベルで見れば
彼がぴったし哲学哲学を語ったんだけど
彼がこんな間違いを犯してないんです
その経典と書いたものは
経典で言った自体でも嘘を言ってるし
こっちはちょっと間違ってるんで間違っていたんだからどうなったかというと
空という真理の状態から現象が現れてくるんだと
それよく考えちゃうと
ヒンドゥー教で言ってる同じことなんです
ブラフマンという実体があって
そこから現象の世界が変化してくるんだと
だから現象の世界は無常ですけど
空はブラフマンは無常じゃないんだと
同じことこちらでも言えるんです
色は無常ですけど 空は無常になるはずがないんですから
だからこのちょっとレールがずれたところはそこなんです
そこでさらに進んで この空は人格化します
人格化して第二に如来というんですね
そちらから発心と呼んで
発心ブッダと発心如来
発心如来というのは空そのもの
真理そのものなんです
でもそちらからどんどん現象の世界が出てくるんだと
それは仏説でもないし
仏教でもなくなっちゃったんですね
だからすごく残念なことで
ほんのちょっとこちらでもずれたとここけたところなんです
これはちょっと子供に聞いたならば
子供教えてくれるのにね
だからもうお寺のお寺とかね
そういう誰かがね もう
作ったでしょうと思いますけど
そんなこのおかしい論理はきれいさっぱりパーリ経典でまるっきりないんです
例えば あのサンカーラは無常であると空であると
で 無我であるというと
逆にじゃあ涅槃は永遠であって幸福であって我ですよと
そんな言葉の遊びはしてないんです
無我ですよという場合は
すべては無我ですよと
涅槃も抜けてないんです
衆生無我と言っているんです
だからこういうふうなことで
A イコール B だから B イコール A ですよと
そういう単純ではダメと
昨日ちょっと話していた時は
友達が言った まあ言ったのは
掛け算でもっとわかりやすいんだ
それはね A 例えば A かける 0 は 0 ですと
B かける 0 は 0 ですと
だからといって A イコール B にはならないんだと
ならないでしょうに だからこの抽象したら
この事実から離れてい
頭の理念だけに考え方だけに持ってきたら
そういう問題が出てきますね
だからこの修行を置いておいて考えるんですね
仏教について そこでちょっと考えすぎちゃったと
そういうことで あの 一応空という実体が成り立つようになってしまった
ですから 空というのは何もないことではないんだと私にも教えてくれちゃったんです
[笑い]ね 従順と言ってみれば
もうそんなことではないんだけど
そのないあるという問題じゃないんですけどね
あ そうですかと笑っていたんですけど
なぜならば僕はサンスクリット語で読んでいるんだからね
一応ほんのわずかなところがずれたんだからね
そういうところで考え方が変わってしまったんです
ですから 結局 これ私だけの個人的な意見なんですけど
そこで間違ったところで
後で宗派部派部派に分かれて仏教変化していったところで
またヒンドゥー的な考え方に戻ってしまったと
お釈迦様 嫌だと出た家にまた戻ったと
偉そうに家を出て 仏教という世界がやっぱり戻りますということで
ものすごい負け犬というかね
お釈迦さんは戻らなかったんですけどね
まあそういうのは まあどうせ人間が考えたりするとね
そういう間違いというかね
そういうことっていうのはありえますけどね
また次から次へとこれ研究していっちゃうと
もっともっともう出ますけどね
でも今日はそういう空論に語る時ではないんだから
空と空は初期仏教でもある言葉だよというだけ理解してください
空という概念というのは
まあこれは大乗仏教だけの概念ということではなくて
私たちにとっても まあいとも簡単に使っていた言葉なんですね
これ数学間違ったんだからね
そこでちょっとおかしいんだと
ですから この解脱を得てもまた戻れるんですね
戻るも戻るんです 空論のもっと持ってきたら
だから空という絶対的な真理に行っても
その絶対真理からまた現象が現れるでしょうし
そこであの菩薩の概念はとても簡単に成り立つんです
菩薩は本当は如来なんですけど
化け物になって観音とかいろいろ変化して人を救うためにまた来るんだと
救われた人はまた向こうに行ったらまた戻るんだから
結局輪廻なんですね 最終解脱とか non 解脱の世界ではなくなっちゃう
だからそういうのはほとんど別に
実際の状況はどうであろうか
この哲学的に分析すると
そういう風に なることはなるんですね
ですから このなんかちょっと初期仏教と今ある大乗仏教
なんかそういう違うところを見るのはそういうところでなんですね
うん  そういうことで えーと
無我理解することは解脱であるという言葉で
あの話を終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございました